Beyonce's publicist responds to the hate
and apparent death threats this woman
has received from this video you've
probably seen the viral moment by now a
woman named Nicole Curran leaning over
Beyonce to talk to jay-z
at the NBA Finals on Wednesday night
fans were quick to point out B's body
language during the interaction saying
things like somebody better tell Becky
she better back up off B though jay-z is
apparently just ordering a vodka soda
you can even see Nicole mouthing
something like do you want lime Nicole
is Golden State Warriors owner Joe wake
up swipe her Instagram was swarmed by
The Beehive leaving B emojis and
according to Nicole death threats
she then posted a photo helping Beyonce
with something getting something out of
her hair it's hard to tell but she
captioned the photo we should all help
and support each other
she later disabled comments made her
Instagram private then disabled her
Instagram entirely but the shade room
captured a response she wrote saying all
of this has been taken out of context
I'm a happily married woman telling me
to kill myself somehow I don't think she
would support this B's publicist event
Noelle sure echoed this addressing the
Beehive on Instagram with a photo of
jay-z and Beyonce during the on the run
to tour quote I know your love runs deep
but that love has to be given to every
human it will bring no joy to the person
you love so much
if you spew hate in her name we love you
[Music]
slow down they don't love you